by the length and Olympic size for
important they actually have to travel
across to this unit that they were
placing so it's going to be hard
physical labor six and a half hours the
spacewalk is going to take the longest
spacewalk ever has been eight hours and
55 minutes it's incredibly hard work
it's dangerous work they train and
they've trained and they trained for it
this is not something they take lightly
at NASA or any of the other space
agencies and just moving is hard isn't
it yeah it's incredibly hard obviously
and the spacesuit they're actually
wearing weighs 350 pounds it doesn't
weigh as much in space because obviously
you haven't got the effect of gravity
but they're very bulky they can't
actually turn their heads in the space
so Tim Peake has to check that tim kopra
isn't tangled up in wires and likewise
tim kopra the American astronaut has to
take that Tim Peake isn't tangled up in
any wires so it can take it can take a
while to do it it's not an easy task but
it's something tim is incredibly excited
about and I think it's difficult to tell
whether these are pictures early or not
but he does look like he is exiting or
has exited the international space
station now what